salut tout le monde voici la suite de
notre galerie de portrait pour la draft
2023 de la NBA on prend les les
meilleurs joueurs de cette classe mais
aussi les Français et on vous donne
l'essentiel voici donc l'essentiel en 20
minutes sur le français Ryan Ruppert
[Musique]
Ryan Rupert est né le 31 mai 2004 il
aura donc 19 ans le soir de la draft un
des plus jeunes joueurs de de cette
cuvée de mètres de mètres de mètres 0,1
87 kilos 5 mesurait récemment au NBA
draft combine sont donc les mensurations
officielles avec une envergure très
impressionnante de quasiment de mettre
de mettre 16 de mettre 17 sur notre big
board donc notre classement je rappelle
que c'est que c'est pas en fonction de
l'équipe qui choisit à cette position
mais c'est vraiment un classement de
valeurs des prospects nous l'avons 31ème
donc ça serait un début de ce retour on
a 31ème meilleur prospect de la classe
chez envergure il était loterie à un
moment donné alors dans certains boards
pas trop les nôtres et il a vu sa cote
baisser cette saison à cause d'une
saison moyenne il jouait en NBA la Ligue
australienne
dans les autres médias américains qui
parlent de la draft 28 26e chez yatletic
18e chez spin 21ème chez zuringer donc
un peu plus haut que chez nous un peu
plus de croyances ou peut-être un peu
moins de match regarder si on veut
danser les dents
pour en parler nous sommes avec notre
spécialiste celui qui couvre la zone NBA
le championnat australien chez envergure
c'est Yacine salut yes
et Thomas donc qui lui couvre aucune
zone en particulier mais qui est dans la
zone un glock frotter exactement le
globe-trotter de la valeur on commence
toujours comme d'habitude par le la
biographie express du joueur Ryan Rupert
donc né le 31 mai 2004 à Strasbourg pour
le reste c'est Thomas qui vous en parle
c'est ça donc un de nos représentant
français à cette draft connu également
depuis très longtemps pour être donc le
fils du regretté Thierry Rupert internal
français au basket donc grande carrière
en tant que joueur de basketball
professionnel il a donc été mis dans le
banc du basket très très tôt il joue au
basket il a il marchait pas encore sur
ces deux jambes donc il a toujours une
balle de basket entre les mains il a
également d'autres personnes connues
dans sa famille notamment sa grande sœur
Iliana Ruppert qui a été championne
l'année dernière en double NBA avec Las
Vegas cette année va jouer du côté du
côté d'astlanta donc une famille de
basketteur depuis longtemps ça l'a fait
baigner dans ce milieu il a donc
commencé à jouer au basket très tôt il a
pris sa première licence à aller dans
Chalon à 4 ans ensuite il a pu jouer du
côté du Mans et il a intégré petit à
petit donc le Pôle France il a joué en
benjamin puis en mini mais il a intégré
ensuite donc l'INSEP et en dernière
saison à l'INSEP c'était le genre majeur
de cette équipe il était meilleur score
à 14 points par match il a également été
représentant avec l'équipe de France sur
les différents tournois d'été notamment
pour penser à l'année dernière où il
était à l'euro du 18 en Turquie à Izmir
je crois avec Bilal Coulibaly avec Sidi
Sissoko donc avec deux autres Français
qui sont attendus à cette draft cet été
alors qu'il avait des propositions pour
rejoindre la proie il a décidé comme
l'an passé avec Ousmane Diagne ou Hugo
Besson de rejoindre l'Australie et plus
précisément la Nouvelle-Zélande en
rejoignant donc les breakers dans le
championnat de division une Australienne
la NBA où il a joué cette saison dans
une équipe qui a fait un fort beau
parcours
qu'est-ce qu'il faisait cette saison
justement oui effectivement c'est ils
sont allés jusqu'en final
l'équipe de
NBA qu'est-ce qu'il faisait dans cette
équipe
18 matchs en tant que titulaire 28 au
total sur la saison avec un temps de jeu
moyen d'un peu plus de 17 minutes
qu'est-ce qu'il faisait pendant ces
minutes
défensivement et offensivement Yassine
quel était son rôle il avait un rôle
j'ai commencé par le défensif très
important car il est un très bon
défenseur
il a impressionné beaucoup de gens du
côté défensif et du côté offensif il
était plus Oofball par moments le voyait
initié des pic and run on a vu qu'il
pouvait pouvait devenir un playmaker
après c'est un porteur de balle
secondaire voire tertiaire
après
son problème a été au niveau de son
efficacité au tir du côté offensif où il
a 35% aussi 23% à 3 points sur 33
tentatives par match
il est très peu agressif offensif il va
deux fois sur la ligne à 71% donc si on
retient Ryan Rupert c'est plus du côté
défensif où là il est très fort et on a
vu des séquences
joueurs adverse
pas force pas tout le temps pas
forcément tout le temps
et il défendait sur quelle position à
peu près sur il pouvait défendre sur le
poste 2 3 de l'équipe adverse ou voir ou
voir le poste
ok plus sur les postes extérieurs
ouais parce qu'il est encore un peu
léger c'est ce qu'on a retenu quand même
avec les mensurations du NBA N88 kg pour
2 m manque de force
quand on veut être un gros défenseur
c'est il faut il faut quand même peser
son poids en NBA regardez les différents
les différents gros défenseurs des
postes de 3 et même un Marcus Smart il
est temps que donc
généralement il vaut mieux être un peu
ouais c'est ça carré quoi et avoir un
gros coffre pour absorber les contacts
après j'oublie de préciser une petite
chose qui est un peu importante c'est sa
blessure beaucoup de la rater deux mois
de compétition
au poignet au poignet pardon
effectivement
je n'ai pas mentionné non plus début de
saison c'est ça
poignée droit donc le poignet qui tire
c'est un droitier effectivement deux
mois de compétition à peu près manqué
avant de revenir pour une bonne partie
de la saison de vie
où on lui a aussi laissé du temps de jeu
en tout cas en saison régulière
c'est ce qui se fait là-bas c'est pas
c'est pas une critique ou quoi c'est le
but aussi de cette ligue c'est de
promouvoir ces jeunes talents et refaire
on faisait partie cette partie du projet
marketing de la NBA de faire jouer les
jeunes qui peuvent un jour aller à une
bière pour ensuite voilà récupérer les
fruits en disant à machin il est passé
par chez nous et maintenant il joue
dans X club
par exemple pour Josh guidée
[Musique]
pourquoi on draft Ryan Rupert si on le
draft
quelle qualité
on va chercher chez lui
comme Yassine Lady c'est du côté de la
défense que ça se passe c'est un des
meilleurs défenseurs handball de la CUV
il a tous les atouts à part un manque de
poids comme la souligner pour bien
défendre handball et la énormément été
en voyant mission sur le portable de
balade verte on a également vu avec
l'équipe de France à l'Euro 18 l'an
passé je vous ai très souvent en tête de
défense pour aller gêner le porteur de
balade verte il a vraiment toute les
qualités pour comment on l'a dit il a
une très bonne taille il fait il fait 2
mètres il y a une énorme envers Dieu de
quasiment 2018 et donc ça lui permet de
gêner beaucoup de profils différents de
porteurs de ballon il est une énorme
activité des pieds et des mains s'ils
promet d'être énorme très gênant pardon
donc sur le porteur de balle franchement
c'est des gens les plus gênants que j'ai
vu sur le porteur de balles il met
toujours la pression que ce soit avec
ses mains il a graisse vraiment le
porteur de balle et ça va lui permettre
de récolter de nombreuses interceptions
et tes meilleurs intercepteurs de l'euro
18 l'an dernier
va pas avoir des très gros chiffres
cette année en NBA vu qu'il n'avait pas
non plus un énorme temps de jeu mais
c'est vraiment un défenseur handball de
très très grande qualité il prend bien
les écrans il aime bien passer au dessus
de des écrans donc il aime bien se
contorsionner sur au dessus de l'écran
pour réussir à passer et ensuite avec
son énorme envergure il arrive à suivre
et à contester les tirs donc il a
vraiment de très très bonne qualité pour
pour défendre un Ball et légalement un
bon sens de la défense pas vol même si
c'est un peu moins bien il est capable
de se prendre un petit cadeau de temps
en temps il est encore un petit peu trop
à attiré par la balle je dirais mais
c'est un joueur sérieux qui a une vraie
magnétique de travail également ça
m'excérieux qu'on peut envoyer en
mission défensive et il a un bon
physique un peu de poids à prendre mais
c'est vraiment un profil défensif de de
premier plan un des meilleurs de la
cuvée donc c'est pour ça qu'on devra
friend repère cette année
qu'est-ce qu'il doit améliorer pour
s'assurer une carrière en NBA Yassine
son efficacité au tir
améliorer son tir à trois points et
parce que je trouve que son Haendel est
plutôt bon il arrive à se créer des
occasions de tir mais pas
malheureusement ça rentre pas dedans
c'est pour ça qu'il a très très peu joué
en playoff il a passé 8 minutes
seulement sur le terrain en moyenne
alors que durant la saison il était à 20
minutes donc je pense que ce qui doit
amener c'est surtout du côté offensif
son efficacité au tir que ça soit au
périmètre ou un poulet parmi distance
et
au niveau playmaking avoir peut-être un
peu plus la balle lui donner un peu plus
la balle parce que il y a eu des flashs
lors de sa gestion lors des piqu'un run
ça lecture je trouve qu'il a un bon cuit
basket quelques flashs au niveau des
passes donc je pense c'est plus offensif
oui c'est plus dans le tir est-ce que tu
vois des des problèmes dans la manière
dont il appréhende ça est-ce qu'il a des
hésitations et ce qui manque de rythme
et ce qu'il a une mécanique bizarre
qu'est-ce que tu peux nous dire
en fait
je pense que sa mécanique est un peu
changé par rapport à son poignet
j'avais vu des spécialistes aussi le
dire sur la sur Twitter on essaie de
voir de s'informer etc qui a un
changement de mécanique
son épaule est plus avancée
et voilà je pense que c'est ça aussi
c'est un problème peut-être mental
à cause de sa blessure au poignet
je sais pas
de shooter évidemment si vous êtes déjà
eu des blessures à votre main forte ou à
votre poignet fort qui chute ou même à
votre coude vous en êtes sans doute
rendu compte par vous même Thomas est-ce
que tu as d'autres choses à ajouter sur
le soit sur le tir en soi soit sur un
autre secteur de jeu
sur le tiers personnellement j'ai des
hésitations même avant sa blessure
notamment à l'euro ou même avant quand
il a une mécanique notamment sur pull-up
assez particulier en surcatiente ça va
déjà premièrement une remise ultra haute
les plus haut que j'ai vu là vraiment en
plus il est très long donc c'est
vraiment très impressionnant c'est
vraiment vraiment très très haut donc ça
c'est un bon point c'est le permet de
tirer sur des clausades au dessus des
défenseurs donc si ça peut être dur de
le contester en cas de chaîne shoot ça
va après sur Full j'ai plus de mal en
fait quand il va prendre un poulet il va
vraiment beaucoup se baisser limite dans
une chaise et le temps de de se remettre
droit en I pour tirer ça va lui prendre
un certain temps ou un temps certain et
du coup il peut être beaucoup plus
facilement en contesté ça peut lui poser
du tort le causer des torts pour pour
tirer après de Rio après je pense pas
que c'est soit un joueur après dribble
en NBA il va principalement se
concentrer sur du catch and shout même
sur des quatre chaines shoot il a encore
un peu d'hésitation en fin de saison
notamment sur les pleurs il y a un match
il fait 1 sur 6
complètement tiré ça laissait ouvert là
pas vraiment des genoux complètement
mais ça c'était pas des gros close out
sur lui clairement donc il va vraiment
avoir aussi ce côté mental il va devoir
réussir à mettre ses tiers vu que cette
année qui a 25 % il est pas durement
défendu comme je l'ai dit donc je pense
qu'il est encore très loin d'être un
shooter ne serait-ce que correct en NBA
il est encore quelques petits soucis
mécaniques je trouve qu'il baisse un peu
trop la balle au niveau quand il va
catch la balle au niveau de sa hanche
gauche pour après remonter donc il a des
améliorations mécaniques un petit peu à
faire je trouve et après ça va être au
niveau de la confiance au niveau du
travail mais en tout cas je pense qu'il
est assez loin d'être un d'être un
solide shooter NBA donc il y a du
travail mais la mécanique est pas non
plus dramatique le pourcentage au lancer
et plutôt honnête donc il y a du travail
à faire mais c'est un travail de longue
haleine mais pourquoi pas y arriver un
jour il en tout cas les capacités à lui
de à lui travailler pour une question
pour vous deux on parle du tir
évidemment c'est ça qui fait le spacing
mais il y a aussi l'intelligence
offensive qui peut parfois compenser
des joueurs qui peuvent être moyen au
tir est-ce qu'il a alors Yassine parlait
de son playmaking mais c'était plutôt
balle en main
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ces
déplacements sans le ballon en attaque
c'est déplacements ou ses actions et ce
qui fait des petits écrans malins est-ce
qu'il participe au bon sens et ce qui a
quelque chose qui peut lui permettre
aussi de sauver ce manque d'adresse
qu'il aura certainement au moins tôt
dans sa carrière parce qu'il va pas
progresser d'un coup si quoi pour moi il
a une très bonne lecture de jeu il
participe pour moi ils participent bien
au jeu que ce soit dans les écrans
des écrans pour libérer son meneur
être toujours en position de tir au
niveau du périmètre même s'il est pas en
confiance moi je trouve qu'il est il est
volontaire
moi pareil comme Yassine l'A10
QI basket il sait se déplacer il
s'éclate c'est un bon joueur transition
également et c'est fini dès demain au
Cercle donc en transition il a pas trop
de problèmes il a un Haendel même si je
trouve qu'il arrive un peu haut
notamment pour porter la portée vraiment
la balle il est capable donc en
transition il y a pas de problème il va
pouvoir remonter le terrain pour aller
finir dès demain non ça genre c'est un
joueur intelligent c'est un joueur qui
comprend le jeu c'est un genre qui sait
faire bouger à bas le même si je pense
pareil qui portera pas la balle en NBA
il sera capable de faciliter le jeu il
est capable de prendre de bonnes
décisions au début de saison on l'a vu
comme l'a dit Yacine qui on lui laissait
un peu de répétition en portant de balle
donc c'est assez intéressant
personnellement le truc qui va un petit
peu freiner en attaque c'est je trouve
qu'il est comme on parlait Yassine au
niveau de la confiance je trouve qu'il a
un manque de confiance pas forcément lui
un peu en son corps même quand il va
quand il va au cercle il est vite
souvent le contact et je le trouve un
petit peu un petit peu évident par
moment donc à voir avec cette attaque de
cercle avec au tir si on laisse tirer
avoir comment tout ça va gérer
mentalement pour lui comment ça va
affecter son développement je le trouve
un petit peu voilà un petit peu
relookant parfois à prendre à prendre
des tirs à aller enfoncer son genre au
contact donc il va devoir prendre du
poids peut-être pour s'affirmer pour
prendre un peu plus confiance en Lui
donc quelques doutes personnellement
mais mais j'espère qu'il va réussir à
surmonter ce problème que je trouve
qu'il avait encore un petit peu trop
cette année et j'ajoute pour les
finitions au Cercle c'est pas par
rapport aux chiffres qu'on a du NBA
combine c'est pas le joueur le plus
athlétique aussi on n'a pas trop parlé
mais c'est un ailier long athlétisme
fonctionnel mais il est loin il est la
7e plus basse détente du compagnie il me
semble c'est ouais top ouais en tout cas
une des plus une des 10 plus basse
effectivement
il a plus des détentes de pivot il est
plus vers une détente max à qui part
peut-être de la détente sèche
détente max de pivot que de que délier
et en ce qui concerne les les vous savez
peut-être pas mais
il y a plusieurs
il y a plusieurs exercices d'agilité
c'est-à-dire
concrètement on doit faire des reprises
d'appui repartir dans notre sens le plus
vite possible et là encore il a pas été
il a pas été top même s'il a pas il a
pas fait le
Shuttle run il a quand même pas eu des
résultats extraordinaires donc ça n'a
pas dû aider
son stock comme on dit
suite à ce NBA compagnie il était pas
dans les pires il était quand même loin
d'être dans les meilleurs joueurs de
cette il était par exemple derrière
azurola stubilis qui est quand même pas
vu pour être un évier fort très très
agile au niveau des appuis
quel rôle l'année prochaine
quel rôle l'année prochaine il faut
qu'il ait pour toi Yassine est-ce que tu
est-ce que tu l'imagines avoir du temps
de jeu ou pas
ça dépend dans quelle équipe il va se
retrouver
mais si il va dans une équipe comme ok
ici les requêtes s'il aura je pense du
temps de jeu après comment on va le
l'utiliser
moi je le verrai peut-être à terme en
améliore son tira à trois points
j'ai du mal à me prononcer sur Ryan
franchement j'ai du mal à le voir là
maintenant l'année prochaine en ligne en
tout cas je le vois plus faire une année
en plus pour que si je trouve que c'est
mieux pour lui
ouais attendre encore un peu d'être plus
mûr quoi pour pas trop se brûler les
altés d'accord Tom ouais je suis
vraiment d'accord avec Yassine en fait
je le vois pas être positif
offensivement en NBA le seul moyen pour
lui de rentrer vraiment dans une équipe
sérieuse après bien sûr il peut jouer
nbase une équipe se met à tanqué avoir
du temps de jeu mais à part sur des
missions défensives je vois pas vraiment
comment ils peuvent vraiment apporter
sur sur un terrain de vie actuellement
donc personnellement pour son
développement ça me dérangerait pas du
tout de le voir en voyant le gilet pour
reprendre confiance améliorer son tir et
même je l'ai dit il pourrait avoir plus
de liberté donc améliorer le reste de
son jeu continuer de prendre un peu de
répétition de bol pour améliorer son
playmaking sont tranchant handball on en
a pas forcément beaucoup parlé mais je
trouve qu'il manque de tranchant à la
main des fois il sait pas vraiment trop
quoi faire quand il se retrouve avec la
balle donc voilà être plus tranchant et
plus incisive dans ses choix améliorer
son tiers donc ouais moi clairement sauf
dans une équipe faible qui joue le bas
de tableau je le vois pas avoir des
minutes rapidement NBA et je pense que
pour son bien il peut il peut aller en
Chili se développer tranquillement en
plus on l'a dit au début de l'épisode il
était très jeune il est né 2004 c'est
des plus jeunes joueurs de la cuvée donc
il y a pas il y a pas de problème à
prendre une année à progresser de son
côté angélique tout à fait tout à fait
il y a des joueurs qui sont prévus dans
le top 6 7 et qui sont au moins un an de
plus que lui donc c'est vraiment tu as
raison de ressouler son âge Yassine
est-ce que tu crois j'y crois tu as le
droit de dire non
plus toi tu es belle
j'y crois que si
l'équipe qui le draft a un vrai projet
avec lui par exemple comme les sports
avec je suis imprimant
là je pourrais
peut-être pas pris le meilleur exemple
c'est le seul que j'ai inventé mais
voilà si voilà je le vois peut-être
réussir dans un projet sérieux ou
vraiment croit vraiment lui on le
développe
oui je vois ce que tu veux dire on parle
pas de l'extrait sportif
qui vient pour le coup d'une famille qui
connaît le professionnalisme donc
pour le coup c'est pas pour ça que c'est
ce genre d'attitude est à exclure
complètement mais il y a quand même des
bases qui sont pas qui sont déjà
acquises probablement et qui sont pas
naturels à tout le monde et qui le sont
à lui puisqu'il a il a grandi dans cet
environnement
professionnel du basketball Thomas on y
croit ou quoi
quelques doutes forcément quelques
doutes notamment sur le tiers comme j'ai
dit plusieurs fois je pense qu'il est
vraiment loin d'être un shooter ok en
NBA par contre il a des vrais qualités
comme on en a parlé défensivement c'est
vraiment très costaud notamment sur
l'homme ça fait le meilleur de la cuvée
je tiens encore à le souligner c'est
vraiment très bien il a défendu comme
des pros cette année même des gens
beaucoup plus petit que lui des jours
assez vif et les tu es capable de les
tenir donc c'est vraiment très bien
offensivement c'est trop bureau pour que
je le sélectionne trop haut
personnellement mais là quand même des
qualités il a un sens du jeu il a un
shoot qui est encore assez loin d'être
viable mais qui a développé c'est pas
catastrophique il a un sens du jeu et
capable de poser la balle par terre il
est capable de distribuer la balle donc
c'est un projet à long terme que
j'achète oui forcément on va essayer d'y
croire mais que j'achète moins ou
d'autres joueurs donc c'est plus un
joueur que je vais acheter en fin de
premier tour à partir des 25 ou en début
de deuxième en gros donc un joueur que
non dans lequel je crois mais mais pas
trop quoi c'est pas un joueur que je
l'achète en fin de l'Autriche ok comme
il était vu passer un temps
en tout cas chez ispienne
merci à toi Thomas merci beaucoup
Yassine vous retrouver nos autres
portraits sur les différentes applis
d'écoute pour trouver les fiches
techniques des joueurs sur envergure.co
ainsi que vos articles notre big board
notre classement des meilleurs prospects
2023 et on se dirige tout doucement vers
la soirée de draft qu'on fera donc chez
First steam salut tout le monde